scientists get to share information and
all work together to try to figure out
what the problem is that a reasonable
well here comes the decision trees like
I wish I could say yeah that's what I
think it is so one possibility is let's
be honest if you are faking UFOs the
last people you want are the world's
most brilliant physicists you give them
the data they're gonna say right oh look
I see what you did you put a couple of
flashlights with lasers into the sky and
you can move them really quickly by the
angle and that creates the allusion to
something zipping through the world if
you're faking a UFO gas the last thing
you want is theoretical physicists on
the case so that would be one reason to
clear them out another reason would be
bureaucracy you've got these rival
groups they're all starved for money
nobody wants to invite somebody smarter
than they are so the problem with a B
level in c-level players is that they're
looking for dnf players so that they're
not threatened that's another
possibility
[Music]